don luís que por acá que como encontrar
un grupo de excombatientes de las
extintas farc ha encontrado un artefacto
pero podemos decir que que puede ser una
una mina antipersonal un campesino les
había avisado de que en su predio podría
haber explosivos de la guerra y no le
fuimos junto a sus compañeros juan
carlos prepara una barricada que reduzca
el daño medioambiental
después mediante una barra de acero van
a disparar contra el artefacto muy lejos
listo vámonos
acá para que no para evitar riesgos los
desminadores se esconden para todas la
unidades y tiene la fuego en un minuto
un riesgo donde una persona puede se
puede un animal se puede accidental lo
estamos quitando pues por eso estos
disparos son mejores que los que
hacíamos antes
fuego en el área
decíamos que se crea contenedor será no
no lo haya visto alguna vez pero puede
ser sí sí sí lo utilizaban como
contenedores de para ser para fabricar
minas humanicemos es el resultado de los
acuerdos de paz entre el gobierno y la
guerrilla de las farc de 2016 aunque su
operación no empezó hasta 2020 reciben
financiación del fondo europeo para la
paz y su actividad está monitoreada por
un más el servicio de acción contra las
minas de las naciones unidas tiene más
de 100 trabajadores y es la primera
organización de desminado del mundo
formada íntegramente por desminadores
firmantes de paz cada día se desplazan a
los remotos lugares que ocupaban cuando
eran combatientes de artefactos que
germán balanta es gerente de terreno en
las farc era comandante la
reincorporación trata de mantener las
estructuras anteriores con un fin muy
diferente fuimos un actor del conflicto
y que también colocamos minas y hoy la
estamos retirando
la vuelta a la vida civil ha significado
una nueva oportunidad
a la chica
cómo estás
[Música]
yo muy feliz en esta vida porque ya soy
una más con mi familia pero el impacto
del desminado también llega a las
comunidades en colombia cada día hay más
de una víctima por minas antipersonal
el área que se despejó el verdader ya
está volviendo a un resguardo de los
indígenas embera chamí apenas un mes
antes devolvieron el territorio libre de
minas podemos caminar en este es por
esta área es muy grato saber eso de
parte de ustedes que también agradecidos
y nosotros es también un desminado que
permite que los niños hoy puedan volver
a pisar los caminos de un futuro que
sueñan que sea de paz